an uninhabitable hell for
millions of people that's what the
planet is becoming due to the lack of
action on climate change that's
according to a strongly worded united
nations report
it says in the past two decades more
than seven 000
major natural disasters have been
recorded
and that figures nearly doubled in the
past 20 years
the increases are mostly attributed to
floods and storms
the u.n is accusing political and
business leaders of willingly
sowing the siege of our own destruction
and says
industrial nations have failed miserably
on reducing greenhouse gas emissions
researchers on the biggest mission to
the north pole have also released some
of their findings
what they've documented is extensive
extensive amounts of sea ice melting
away
and they predict there'll be ice-free
arctic summers
within the next few decades let's bring
in dennis mclean who's a spokesman for
the united nations office for disaster
risk reduction
who are behind this particular report
today he's joining us from
geneva thanks for speaking to us so
pretty pretty grim reading i would
describe this report as i mean talk us
through some of the data that you came
up with and what stood out for you
well the first thing is to say that
tomorrow is international day for
disaster risk reduction
and what we are trying to highlight by
publishing this report
is the need to strengthen disaster risk
governance
so that governments un member states put
in place
national strategies for managing risk
reducing disaster risk
with clear vision and competent uh
agencies to to put these strategies into
effect
because if we don't the the future looks
very bleak indeed because
over the last 20 years we've recorded
over 3 000 more extreme weather events
that happened in the previous 20 years
and of course that's just not
sustainable if it continues
again for the next 20 years to double uh
it's simply the case that member u.n
member states governments are not
delivering on the commitments that they
made five years ago
when they adopted uh framework
agreements like the paris agreement on
climate
and the sendai framework for disaster
risk reduction which is designed to
reduce disaster losses
by 2030 but we do see now around the
world that we are losing the battle to
eradicate poverty
and to bring down disaster losses right
so what then what is your message to
governments on how they can
better prepare uh for the looming
disasters as you call them
because clearly in this report you are
pointing the finger at governments
yes i mean in the long term what we need
to do is to see
progress on reducing greenhouse gas
emissions so that we avoid catastrophic
climate change at the moment we're on
track
for a 3.2 degree rise in in global
temperatures
compared to pre-industrial levels at the
moment we're at fi
we're at one degree or more and we
already see the impact of that in the in
the rise in extreme weather events i
mean
floods have more than doubled in the
last 20 years we've seen a huge
increase in the number of storms and
we're only now beginning to understand
the impact of extreme temperatures
on wildfires drought and and
heat waves and interesting apologies but
your own data is showing that asia
suffered the highest number of disasters
over the past 20 years and then followed
by the americas and then africa
that's correct asia is the most
disaster-prone part of the world and
of course it's the most densely
populated part of the world and we can
see also that
asia is also bearing the brunt of the
covert 19 pandemic
asia also has done a very good job in
some
cases of reducing loss of life from
disasters i mean i would cite the
example of
bangladesh where 50 years ago 1 million
people died in the cyclone of november
1970
and recently we had another cyclone in
bangladesh of similar magnitude
and only 19 people died the
difference in those 50 years is that the
government
has taken action decisively they've put
in place a very effective cyclone
preparedness program
which has significantly reduced the loss
of life in the
in the affected coastal areas because
they've got a very good early warning
system
uh huge numbers of volunteers
disseminating the warnings
and the warnings lead to early early
action people evacuating in good time
and that's a good model on which to base
pandemic preparedness
and other uh preparedness programs that
need to be put in place to reduce the
loss of life
right so when you say that floods and
storms have been the most frequent
disasters over the past two decades but
looking ahead
the warning is that the worst problem is
going to be heat waves
the worst well it will be the worst
problem but it'll certainly be a very
significant one because we'll get
we're going to get better at measuring
it most of the data we have on heat
waves
and mortality related to heatwaves comes
from
western europe and more sophisticated
economies
but there is no doubt that many many
deaths from heatwaves
are going unrecorded around the world
and we need to improve
our data collection to understand better
the uh
the impact that this is having on the
lives of ordinary people especially
in low and middle income countries but
there is no doubt
the problem is getting worse and
effective measures have to be put in
place
to reduce mortality and the other
impacts we're seeing from heat waves
especially
when it comes to food security dennis
mclean we thank you very much for
speaking to us
from geneva
thank you